قالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان لنا بير
بوك ان مجموعه السبع اتفقت على مواصله دعم
اوكرانيا بمنظمات الدفاع الجوي واضفت
تنبير بوك في مؤتمر صحفي مع نظيرها
الدنماركيه برلين انه سيتم بحثه ما يمكن
القيام به اكثر لدعم الشعب الاوكراني مره
اخرى وفقه التعبير بوك
مره اخرى بوضوح شديد اليوم اننا لن نتوانا
عن دعمنا لاوكرانيا ما دامت رو شنو هذه
الحبه العدوانيه الوحشيه وغير القانونيه
يدافع شعب اوكرانيا بشجاعه عن حريتنا وعن
النظام السلام الاوروبي وعليه سنقف الى
جانبه دون اي شرط وسنساعده وفي مقدمه
المساعده من اجل الحياه انظمه الدفاع
المضاد للطائرات ولقد اتفقنا الان مره
اخرى مع مجموعه السبع على تكثيف تعاوننا
في مجال الدفاع الجوي